even before she was a fully fledged
doctor kate barker always had a
fascination for the outdoors growing up
being out among nature felt like she was
connected to the wider world one part of
a larger hole she intuited from a very
young age that the earth had a system in
place full of millions if not billions
of parts that all work together in the
hopes of achieving perfect balance
humans animals and insects right down to
the germs that were so small they
couldn't be seen unless under a
microscope and then of course there were
the plants trees flowers and all manner
of other flora that provided the world
with so much more than making it look
beautiful and it was so much so that a
young kate wanted to devote her life to
helping maintain our beautiful little
blue and green planet and understand
every part of it the way she did that
changed as the years went on as a child
that was learning how trees take in
carbon dioxide and water then used the
sun's energy to feed themselves and
produce oxygen through a process known
as photosynthesis
then in high school kate was writing and
giving presentations on the importance
of protecting the environment and
conserving wildlife trying to convince
her classmates to see the world in the
same way she did by the time college
rolled around that protection took on a
seemingly more proactive form standing
out on picket lines in protest when the
college announced it would be chopping
down its nearby woods to expand the
campus eventually she was made dr kate
barker and awarded her phd in botany and
plant science she thought that would be
when the real work began having climbed
her way up to achieving her degree was
only the first step the next would
involve working tirelessly to keep the
world's greenery alive after all kate
had studied for years learning about
anything and everything to do with plant
life their different functions and
structures how each species had evolved
and could be classified and how they all
formed part of the planet's ecosystem
unfortunately even for those with a
noblest of intentions the harsh
unforgiving laws of reality can tend to
get in the way in kate's case that came
in the form of being snapped up for a
job at a genetic research company sure
on the one hand she did get to rely on
all the information she had learned on
her way to earning her phd but on the
downside all kate got to use her
knowledge for was receiving and tending
to various plant samples getting asked
occasionally to run tests on said
samples was about the pinnacle of
excitement in her job somehow despite
working with plants dr barker couldn't
help but feel further away from nature
than she had ever been that was until an
unusual specimen was brought to her
department for analysis something unlike
anything kate had seen in all her years
of research and study although she
didn't know it at the time this unique
plant would bring dr barker closer to
nature in a way she could never have
imagined because it was a sample of
scp-306 of course at the time and even
after the plant's anomalous properties
began to take effect kate was completely
unaware of this when it was first
brought to her lab it seemed like just
an ordinary fungus no one had been able
to successfully identify it however but
if anyone could dr kate barker was
perhaps the best qualified person where
was it found she asked the lab
technician as he handed her the sample
secured in a sealed airtight container
pretty close to here apparently the lab
tech replied louisiana swamps are always
full of mushrooms and stuff like this
right yes that's true there are quite a
few different fungi native to louisiana
kate answered instinctively like her
brain was on autopilot she was more
focused on examining the sample in the
box than the conversation uh thing is no
one knows what kind this is or if it's
dangerous i heard a rumor the locals
used to call it frog rot but apparently
that was an older name for it the
technician added garnering a little more
than a mumble of agreement from the
doctor of botany kate placed the clear
perspex container near the window
letting the natural light of the
outdoors give her a better look at what
was inside it was a portion of a dead
tree it sparked soggy and darkened from
the swamp water growing out of its side
was a cluster of the mysterious fungus
in question looking more like pustules
or a cyst a tumor growing out of the
dead wood as if it had drained the
bigger plant of all of its life kate's
next few hours were spent taking samples
of the fungus keeping her hands and face
covered as she scraped away parts of it
to examine under her microscope there
was little abnormal about it on a
cellular level nothing in testing to
suggest that the sample was toxic or
directly harmful all cake could decipher
about the plant was that it was related
to a certain genus of fungi known as
trichophyton which includes the same
parasitic varieties of fungus that can
cause athlete's foot ringworm and
similar infections in humans still
unable to fully identify the species
kate decided to take a closer look at
how it was growing putting the container
behind a safety screen she opened it up
and began to pull apart the sodden tree
bark with her gloved hands there was
definitely some kind of mass underneath
the bark what kate initially assumed to
be the wood of the tree that the fungus
had taken root to nothing could have
prepared her for how wrong she was as
the bark split apart and crumbled away
it revealed what was underneath a
cottontail swamp rabbit the fungi took
on even more of a tumor-like appearance
when dr barker saw that it was actually
growing out of the rabbit's back having
actually taken root within the poor
creature's body as much as the sight of
it was profoundly upsetting even a
little sickening the scientists and kate
knew that this was all just part of
nature taking its course once she got
over the initial shock it was even a
little fascinating her botanical
expertise was second to none and through
that knowledge she knew that more fungi
grew in damp conditions but she had
never seen any genus grow from the
biological matter of another organism
dead nor alive could this mystery
species grow in any biomass even in a
human being worried about that
possibility kate went to store the
scp-306 sample until further testing
could be conducted as she placed it back
in the container her hand nudged one of
the fungi's bulbs causing it to expel a
wisp of tiny spores not that she could
see them of course they were
microscopically small but as they
drifted through the air the spores were
drawn to kate up and towards where she
was steadily breathing the minute the
spores slipped undetected into her
airway dr barker immediately began
coughing feeling a disgusting earthy
tang at the back of her throat she
couldn't stop spluttering instinctively
raising her hand to cover her mouth her
rubber gloves were still covering her
fingers coating in even more invisible
residue from the fungus and now kate was
unknowingly breathing in more excusing
herself from work from the rest of the
day dr kate barker went home feeling
sicker and sicker as every minute passed
a fever was rapidly climbing limbs were
shuttering and still she couldn't stop
coughing and spluttering as she tried to
expel a foul lingering sensation that
refused to leave her throat but those
weren't even the worst symptoms two days
had come and gone since the incident at
the lab and kate still hadn't returned
to her job how could she she felt awful
and looked far worse large lesions had
started appearing on her skin rapidly
turning into warts just looking at them
made kate's stomach turn and on a few
occasions poking at them and feeling
these alien lumps on her skin caused her
to vomit every night she would go to bed
her body rapidly switching from
sweltering hot then becoming cold enough
to cause kate to shiver uncontrollably
at first it looked like the lesions were
clearing falling away from her skin soon
after they had fully formed into warts
but the fleeting bit of hope that gave
her was quickly wiped away when new ones
started to grow in their place this
didn't just feel like the flu or any
other type of sickness for that matter
it felt painful on the deepest tiniest
level during what little restless sleep
she did get kate kept having nightmares
about doctors looking at her cells under
a microscope watching them changing into
something else it had been over two
weeks since she had first been exposed
to
scp-306's spores and still she hadn't
been well enough to get back to work
each time kate had called the human
resources department to inform them that
she still wasn't any better they always
came out with the same advice drink
plenty of fluids try to eat and keep
your strength up dr barker hadn't
stopped eating or drinking albeit at a
very slightly reduced rate her appetite
had been sapped along with most of her
energy although she had noticed that she
dropped a significant amount of weight
in an alarmingly short amount of time
three weeks later kate flicked on the
bathroom light and barely recognized
herself not only was she no longer at a
healthy weight but her skin something
was very wrong with her skin she had
developed an abnormal pigmentation a
yellowish green a shoe almost like she
had somehow developed jaundice but to
the touch it felt a strange almost
rubbery texture in fact if she hadn't
felt so sick kate would have noticed
that her skin wasn't absorbing water the
way it was used to either displaying the
same type of permeability as the skin of
most amphibians two months had gone past
and nobody at the research company had
heard a word from kate she wasn't
answering her phone a few of them were
asked to go to her apartment to check on
her but she never came to the door
either none of them had any idea what
had happened they certainly didn't know
about the changes that her body had
undergone and none of them painlessly
either the constant pain kate had been
feeling had gradually built and built
until it felt like parts of her body
were twisting and contorting against her
will and in unnatural ways with the
grinding feeling of her bones pulling
each other as they shrank her limbs were
wracked with unbearable agony at the
same time her stomach had shrunk to the
point where she wasn't even able to eat
anymore the same reduction was occurring
to the rest of her organs too heart
liver lungs brain everything was getting
smaller shrinking organs imprisoned
within the skeleton that was also
decreasing in size then one morning the
pain had seemingly stopped after a night
spent screaming in sheer agony tears
streaming down her face kate woke up on
the floor of her apartment under a pile
of her clothes but as she awoke she
instantly noticed something everything
looked bigger the whole room towered
above her like she had been reduced down
to the size of something much smaller
than a human she tried opening her mouth
to say something anything but her lips
couldn't form words anymore her arms
felt strange too like their reach was
somehow much shorter the same with her
legs that were now tucked under her body
her tiny rubbery skinned body scp
scp-306
had turned her into a frog it took kate
almost an entire day to figure out how
to properly move around first needing a
long time to emotionally process what
had happened to her if she had still
been able to she would have been sick
and cried endlessly wailing on the floor
instead when she tried to make any noise
a tiny croak was all that emanated from
the back of her horse throat but before
she could find a way to leave her
apartment something else found their way
in from way down on the floor the men in
their white hazard suits looked colossal
impossibly tall kate tried her best to
dodge between the thick soles of their
heavy boots as they came crashing down
towards her from above each one having
enough force behind it to crush her in
an instant she leaped out of the way of
one descending boot only to be caught
mid-air in a glass container as the lid
screwed tightly shut sealing her inside
kate was lifted up and saw a patch of
the hazmat uniforms of the men that had
come to take her away a black circle
with three arrows pointing in towards
its center and an outline surrounding it
the foundation put her in a glass tank
with 11 other frogs each of them looking
almost identical to kate all climbing
over each other fighting for their own
space in the tiny enclosure from the
moment she arrived kate could see the
same thing in their gaze as they could
see in hers sadness unmistakable even in
those dark beady little eyes these were
people or at least they had been human
beings at some point but now anything on
the outside that had made them unique
their individuality had been taken away
and their minds had all been locked
inside the same frog shaped body as kate
now found herself in over the next few
months the foundation had their
scientists running a series of tests on
the frogs who are now all categorized
under the collective designation of
scp-306-1 even though she was unable to
speak kate recognized their methodical
scientific process how they would test
one or two of the frogs at a time note
the results then change a variable and
repeat the test to see if there were any
changes it was the same process she used
to go through every time a new sample
arrived at her lab watching the
researchers reminded her of her old job
the life she'd worked so hard for and
was cruelly reminded that it was all
gone now nobody would ever know where
she went she'd never be able to go out
amongst nature in the way that she had
always loved kate had long since figured
out the root cause of her transformation
a while after she had started to feel
sick she'd wonder if that strange fungus
had anything to do with it seeing all
the foundation scientists and guards in
their hazmat gear only handling the
other frogs with thick rubber gloves
seemed to prove her theory right and
suggested that she and her fellow
amphibians were still infectious still
she currently had no way of
communicating with the foundation
personnel about what had caused her to
change although they seemed as if they
already knew
most of the tests involved the
researchers putting kate and the other
frogs into mazes or making them solve
puzzles or memorizing commands naturally
having once been human they all picked
it up quicker than the researchers
expected from their perspective these
frogs were displaying an extremely
advanced form of intelligence gradually
the testing progressed and the
foundation's researchers began
attempting to teach the frog specimens
to read and write all skills that they
had already possessed even if some of
them needed some time to learn how to
hold a pen in their new sticky fingers
kate herself was made to complete an iq
test scoring 127 points now that she had
a way to communicate with these
scientists through writing notes she and
the other
scp-306-1s were asked their names that
was the moment the foundation realized
what they were these weren't just frogs
but human beings who are now trapped in
the bodies of frogs perhaps inspired by
this human to frog transformation or
possibly as some cruel joke one of the
foundation researchers who went by the
name thompson brought in a children's
book and presented it to the collection
of
scp-306-1 specimens at first kate
enjoyed the simplicity of the stories
and it seemed her fellow frogs did as
well but gradually they all grew
depressed maybe one of the stories
featuring a prince being turned from a
frog back into human form while the 12
remaining specimens had yet to be
presented with a magical cure for their
condition or perhaps seeing something as
simple as a children's book reminded
some of the frogs of all they were still
to do in their old lives like starting
families and now they wouldn't get the
chance kate and some of the other frogs
began writing notes to thompson and
another of the researchers who had been
feeding them phyllis they did their best
to be reasonable with the foundation but
also communicate how desperately they
want it to be set free you have no right
to keep us here kate wrote under the
towering stare of phyllis and thompson
feeling for the first time in a long
while that she was actively doing
something to make a difference in nature
we need to be out in the world we need
to be free if she had more space on the
paper she would have tried to note down
suggestions of places the frogs could be
introduced where they wouldn't pose any
risk of disrupting the local ecosystem
the swamps of louisiana where the
scp-306 fungus had been found were one
such idea that came to mind but much to
dr kate barker's disappointment she and
her fellow frogs would only cause the
fungi's infectious properties to spread
meaning their pleas with the foundation
fell on deaf ears there was no other
choice nothing else they could do they
needed to break out as night fell kate
organized the frogs gradually writing
out instructions for how they were going
to escape communicating with them the
same way she had with the researchers
only this time the others listened even
if they couldn't be human again they
didn't want to live the rest of their
short lifespans being locked up and
tested forever kate marked down the time
that thompson and phyllis usually fed
the frogs and drew up a detailed
strategy if she could hide for long
enough under the others it might make it
seem like one of the specimens was
missing the next day researcher thompson
and researcher phyllis arrive to feed
the
scp-306-1 specimens accompanied by
security guards as always while her
colleague went to collect the feed for
her to administer phyllis did a count of
the frogs 11. she counted again only to
get the same result there was one
missing as she leaned closer to the tank
kate trusted her fellow amphibians above
to follow the plan in a flash the mass
of frogs had leaped from their
containment and pinned phyllis to the
ground as one the room erupted into
chaos people turned frogs leaping in all
directions as they scattered and made a
mad dash for freedom a gunshot rang out
from one of the security guards trying
to subdue the creatures only for the
stray shot to catch researcher thompson
in the neck killing him leading the
charge on her tiny rubbery legs kate
jumped closer and closer to the exit it
was so close if she could just get far
enough away she might finally be free to
get back to nature now go and check out
scp-323 the wendigo skull to hear
another terrifying tale of anomaly that
could cause someone to undergo a
horrific transformation process or if
you're in the mood for more particularly
peculiar plant life why not try
scp-2800 cactus man